j'ai l'impression que c'est une blague
bonsoir à tous merci beaucoup je
voudrais immédiatement partager ce césar
avec les deux grands absents de ce soir
pour moi nicolas pariser le réalisateur
de ce film et fabrice luchini parce que
cette aventure merveilleuse a commencé
avec ces deux là dans la cuisine de
fabrice luchini et nous lisions ce
scénario qui parlait de politique qui
parlait de démocratie et qui parlait de
la puissance de certaines idées on était
tous les trois et c'était déjà très
joyeux c'est un film que j'aime
énormément parce qu'il contient de
l'intelligence il contient de la
délicatesse et il contient de l'humour
ce qui est une chose à laquelle je tiens
beaucoup
ces trois qualités ce sont les qualités
de nicolas pariser leur éditeur de ce
film
merci nicolas je regrette tellement que
tu sois pas dans cette salle je voudrais
te dire vraiment combien cette rencontre
a été essentiel pour moi fabrice luchini
merci si tu m'entends je pense pas pour
bata virtuosité tonton d'enthousiasmé
cette énergie de jeunes débutants
presque c'était merveilleux de jouer
avec ton sens du rythme voilà nicolas
fabrice caezar et pour vous aussi
je voudrais le partage aussi avec tous
mes partenaires brillant de ce film
léonie simaga à north hamdaoui pascal
rénéric alexandre tiger antoine
reinhardt von zeppelin il était super
c'était harmonieux de bout en bout ce
film merci à manuela nuray le producteur
aussi et l'équipe technique des gens
subtil délicat enfin voila c'était
vraiment fantastique
jusqu'à ce soir donc je me réjouis comme
vous le constatez qu est ce que je
pourrais dire d'autre je voudrais
remercier les gens qui m'ont permis de
faire du cinéma avant tout mes parents
pour leur confiance et la liberté qui
m'ont offerte et puis l'amour
ce qui n'est pas rien mes deux soeurs
camille et jeanne et mon frère stéphane
déjà parce qu'ils existent
et puis parce qu'il m'a aimée un jour
poussé il a insisté pour que j'aille à
ce casting avec cet allemand cet
autrichien que je ne connaissais pas et
qui était michael haneke voilà merci
stéphane parce que c'est lui qui m'a
poussé à y aller et j'y suis allé
et c'était une rencontre extraordinaire
merci à l'obstination de sa directrice
de casting chris de bel air et merci à
toi michael ii m'a fait découvrir le
cinéma dans des conditions aussi
incroyable les meilleures conditions
voilà je remercie grégory veille mon
agent pour son amitié et son talent
c'est probable je voudrais remercier qui
d'autre bas les gens qui sont qui
m'entourent
voilà les gens que j'aime et et puis
voilà dire que ce césar il a une saveur
particulière ce n'est pas une année
comme les autres
j'ai l'impression que les paroles se
sont libérés sur des sujets graves et
c'était important et et je voudrais
partager ce césar avec toutes les
actrices qui était nommé ce soir aussi
les absentes kim ont ébloui au cinéma
cette année je pense à hafsia herzi à
virginie efira ariane ascaride à
catherine deneuve
voilà je voudrais les saluer je pense
que c'est célébrer les actrices célébrer
les femmes qu'elles sont et je voudrais
partager ça avec toutes les femmes et
dire aussi que le cinéma est une fête et
que depuis que je suis enfant je j'en
fais et je suis portée par le regard
brillant et la vision de certains
cinéastes des hommes et des femmes
vive le cinéma voilà merci beaucoup
pourvu que ça dure
[Applaudissements]